the best place to get vaccines is in the
buttocks
well as much as i love the buttocks i
have to say that
primarily vaccines can also be received
in your arms
myth 7 it is not necessary to vaccinate
babies
it is definitely necessary to vaccinate
babies vaccines are not tested enough
this is definitely a myth because
vaccines are
tested all the time hi my name is dr
nipuni rajapaksi i'm a pediatric
infectious disease specialist i am maria
elena
and i am a microbiologist virologist and
vaccinologist today we'll be debunking
some common vaccine myths
myth one if the disease has been mostly
eliminated in my country
i don't need a vaccination so this is a
common question that we get
if we all lived in a bubble and there
was no movement of people
this myth might hold true but we know
because of travel and movement of people
around the world
even if a vaccine preventable disease
has been eradicated from a certain area
it can easily be
reintroduced and you can come in contact
with that disease the only
infection that has been eradicated from
the entire world is smallpox and that
was largely done through vaccination
we've come close to eradicating other
vaccine-preventable diseases like polio
but unfortunately
we have not quite made it there yet and
many of these infections
are still present in different parts of
the world myth number two
there's no use getting a vaccine that's
less than a hundred percent effective
that is absolutely not true because any
vaccine
brings some level of protection by
having your body
practiced while it's awaiting to get
exposed with
the real pathogen so even if you get
exposed
and you are partially protected that
will mean that you will be
getting a less severe disease you
probably will not need to get
hospitalized
and they probably can recover faster
most of the childhood vaccines are
somewhere between 85-95
effective depending on the exact vaccine
and the person that you're giving it to
so how effective a vaccine is depends on
both the vaccination itself as well as
your own
immune system response to it myth number
three
vaccines give you the disease that they
are meant to prevent
so this is definitely a myth there's
confusion
because you may be getting some symptoms
when you get the vaccines for example
fever or you know sore at the side of
the infection and it gives the
perception that you're getting
a disease but vaccines are not
going to give you the disease the whole
reason for vaccination
is to expose your immune system to kind
of trick it into thinking it has been
exposed to the infection so that it has
a chance to practice
and develop protection myth four
vaccines can cause
autism there's been a lot of evidence
that vaccines do not cause
autism where the question came about
mostly relates to
a study that was published in the late
1990s by
an investigator who eventually was found
to
be publishing fraudulent information
essentially made up data
and had his license revoked and is no
longer allowed to practice
medicine and so that made its way into
the media and
has caused a lot of damage we've had a
lot of kids who have not received their
measles mumps and rubella vaccines and
have developed measles and ended up with
lifelong sequelae
from that and so people have looked at
this they've studied it
time and time again multiple different
studies looking at hundreds of thousands
of children in different countries and
no link has been found between
vaccines and autism so myth number five
it's not safe to get more
than one vaccine at a time this is false
our immune systems are very powerful
systems within our body and they're
designed
to react and respond to many different
pathogens
infections simultaneously and the number
of
antigens we say that you are exposed to
in a vaccine
is pretty minuscule compared to the
number of things that you come across
in your daily life and so it is
definitely safe to get more than one
vaccine at a time
myth six the best place to get vaccines
is
in the buttocks most of the times
they're being given in your
arms because you can also look at a lot
of the site of injection and how it
reacts
and it's because it's probably closer
also to arriving to indeed the most
important
immune cells and where the immune cells
locate so that then the response can
become systemic
for most children or younger children
sometimes the vaccine can be given into
the thigh
as well so the thigh and the arms are
the most common places that vaccines are
given now
myth seven it is not necessary to
vaccinate babies
infants and young children are really
part of our population that stands to
benefit the most from
getting their routine vaccines the way
that our vaccine schedule
is developed in the united states is to
provide kids especially with
immunity to infections at the times
where they're most vulnerable
or at highest risk of developing severe
disease if they get the infection
and so that's why in the first year of
life we provide many vaccines to kids
because
that is the age group where they're at
the highest risk if they were to become
ill with one of these pathogens
there are many conditions for example
whooping cough that we know children
under six months of age are
at the highest risk of needing to be
hospitalized or dying if they get the
infection and therefore it is definitely
necessary to vaccinate babies and it
provides them with protection
against many serious diseases myth
number eight
vaccines are not tested enough this is
definitely a myth
because vaccines are tested all the time
yes i completely agree vaccines are
amongst the most
studied things that we use in medicine
and
they're evaluated all the way from the
lab until after they're deployed and
used in the general population
so vaccines get tested when we're
evaluating them
in pre-clinical settings in the
laboratory
they are very much evaluated when we're
doing experimental
trials phase one trials phase two trials
large phase three trials and there's
also testing
even after their approval myth number
nine
the effectiveness of vaccinations has
never been proven
vaccines have been in some situations
effective enough that they have
eradicated disease from the planet and
smallpox as the example there
or have allowed us to become very close
to eradicating diseases such as polio
these vaccine preventable diseases are
becoming less common
as we maintain high levels of
vaccination in the general population
when the vaccines are approved and they
start being deployed at large scales
more information is gathered to
determine the effectiveness of the
vaccine so effectiveness is a result
of showing that they work in
large large numbers of populations myth
10 vaccines can contain harmful
ingredients so this is definitely a myth
so i
work specifically in vaccine production
in our laboratories we have to assure
that the ingredients are disclosed and
we have to assure that the ingredients
are
part of what is called acceptable
ingredients that have proven that they
are not going to be harmful
especially to human populations so many
additional
ingredients aside from the vaccine
components themselves that you might see
listed
in a vaccine are there to make the
vaccine safer in many
cases or to increase their effectiveness
and so you might see something like
aluminum
added to boost the immune system
response and it's important to realize
how tiny the amounts of these things in
the vaccine are
and that a child who is breastfed or fed
formula ingests much more
aluminum in their diet than they would
ever get through any vaccination
myth 11 is better hygiene practices mean
you don't need
vaccines it's not going to protect you
100 but especially pathogens that are
transmitted through mosquitoes
or any other type of vectors you know
hygiene alone
is probably not going to prevent you
being exposed to potential
very very bad pathogens myth 12
doctors only recommend vaccines because
that's how they make money
vaccine companies in fact do not even
make a lot of money because now this is
practically a common good
so this is not a one of the essential
medicines that really come with
any kind of economic attachment vaccines
are a public health intervention they
have actually done some studies to look
at it
and in many situations once you factor
in all of the things that are needed to
deliver a vaccine safely to someone so
storage purchase of the vaccine itself
personnel for your clinic when they've
looked at pediatricians who do a lot of
vaccination in our country in many cases
they have actually found that they lose
money by giving vaccines and so it's
quite the opposite of this
but we all do it and we recommend it
because we know that it is
one of the best things we can do to keep
our kids safe and healthy
so our last myth is vaccines have
microchips that
track you vaccines do not have
microchips as you know we have to one
disclose all the components of the
vaccine formulation
and right now there are no devices that
are approved to be combined with the
vaccine formulation
where people may get confused is
sometimes the packaging of a vaccine or
a vaccine vial
could have information on it that they
use to track who got the vaccine so that
if there's any issues they know which
patient
to contact or so that that information
can go directly into your medical record
but there are no
microchips within the vaccines
themselves or that are being injected
into any patients for tracking
as a vaccine developer i would add that
also if you would like to understand how
vaccines have been evaluated
during the experimental trials is that
you could go into the food and drug
administration
site and that paired with information of
course that is provided to you by your
primary care physician
it's probably the best location where
you can look for
veritic and trustworthy information